dozens of Palestinians have been injured
after the Israeli army fired from a
bullets and tear gas as students and
officials who were protesting the
closure of a Palestinian school that
served two villages in the West Bank the
closure means that five hundred children
will no longer receive an education
there
the Israeli army is foreign tear gas
bullets
and sound bombs at our children why just
because Palestinian students come here
to learn the occupation authorities
denies even the right to education
[Music]
hello a year we brought our children to
the school because we want them to study
just like other kids all over the world
the decision to close the spot violates
their rights to education and we reject
them
while the Israeli army says the reason
for the school closures that some of the
students there have been throwing stones
from its grounds claiming that the
facility has produced acts of terror the
IDF has now declared the school a closed
military zone
meanwhile aid agencies warned too that
there are at least 61 schools in the
West Bank that are under threat of
demolition from Israel they see it as a
violation of children's basic rights to
an education the editor of the news
website Palestine Chronicle vamsi brood
says the demolitions are actually a
pretext for seizing more territory for
illegal Israeli settlements they need
land and they need the land of a lab and
they need land of other villages and
this is why the targeting of these of
these areas so basically it usually
starts with the confiscation of
Palestinian land then the targeting of
any Palestinian who dares protests then
declaring more and more Palestinian land
to be closed of military military zone
and eventually this closed of areas are
joined by or are added to the illegal
Jewish settlements that are in constant
expansion this is a story that that
really goes to the heart of Israel in a
correlation of the West Bank this is
about building settlements and of course
they would find every possible pretense
in order for them to put the blame on
the Palestinians who are fighting for
their right and they are fighting for
their freedom
you